yo what's up guys it's mark Spradling
here from mkbhd and I have another
hardware unboxing video for you guys
I've been alternating back and forth
between hardware and software here so
yes this is what I think is I am
thoroughly impressed already with the
shipping how fast this actually have
shipped to my house so yeah let's just
get right into it and we'll see exactly
what we have here so let's go and this
will obviously like the rest of my
unboxing videos I'll give my my first
impressions of the products and
everything like that it will give a a
full review video in one to two weeks so
here we have a an envelope again this
coming from fleischman-hillard
communications so I'll check that out
afterwards and here we go further into
the box and yes this is what I thought
it was this is the audio PSP and as you
put a link in the description so you
guys can check this out these are the
perfect fit earphones or PFE and that's
what it says at the bottom left hand
side of the box there and if we flip it
around you can you can read a lot about
this product and I'll definitely go over
a lot of this in the review video so you
guys can tell exactly where you're
getting should you decide to get this
now I am impressed with the shipping
because this in fact did take this was
overnight shipping from a different
state so you guys I'm definitely
impressed with the critics shipping lis
definitely our into quality service and
support at audio so that sounds a great
job on their part and again you can
check out the link to this company and
this exact product in the description so
as we take this out of the box here
you'll see there's a little a little
booklet here telling you a little bit
about the about the in uh what are you
call about the earphones and a few
different language is actually giving
you a few warnings you know scattered
paperwork and it will tell you actually
what comes in the box so let's keep
going to see everything that we get in
the box so I'll just put this right here
we're just going to take this off the
top right here and yes there's a lot
more in the box what you can actually do
is just I'm going to just put these off
to the side but underneath is a carrying
case and these are the earphones himself
the carrying cases right here and I do
like headphones and companies you know
that provide a little extra stuff
instead of just the headphones instead
of just one thing they'll give you a
carrying case they'll give you these
little hooks that will go on your ears
just say you want to use these during a
workout or when you're running or
something you'll also get different size
earbuds and you'll also get this and
this and I'll definitely show you guys
exactly what these are and you can
probably find more information about
them again in these different user
manuals so these it says user guide and
these books are in different languages
so I probably won't use this one this is
the user guide actually this is the
entire user guide
it'll describe everything about the
headphones and I would definitely I
can't wait to get you guys with a full
review video of this product again
thanks to the folks at audio for sending
me a pair of the P FES and I can't wait
to get you guys with a video so thanks
for watching the unboxing and I hope you
enjoy if you haven't already subscribed
you can do so up there on that yellow
button and that is basically it thanks
for watching guys peace